[Música]
gracias bueno quien de ustedes no ha
disfrutado de un hermoso paisaje alguna
vez un paisaje de esos que recuerden hay
alguien por aquí alguno especialmente en
guatemala bueno pues nosotros hemos
tenido la dicha de recorrer diferentes
senderos y nos hemos quedado tal cual
petrificados admirando respirando o
sintiendo lo que la madre naturaleza nos
transmite a través de estos lugares que
nos dejan sin aliento hemos tenido la
dicha de poder recorrer guatemala desde
cero metros a nivel del mar hasta llegar
a cumbres de volcanes he podido
disfrutar a mis consentidos
tranquilamente he podido regresar
renovada he dejado mi estrés por ahí lo
hemos podido hacer también en familia
este es un momento muy memorable en mi
vida nos decidimos involucrar en el reto
del montañismo y hemos tenido la dicha
de poder estar desde una cumbre del
volcán chingo que es la frontera con el
salvador hasta un tacaná que es la
frontera con méxico y la verdad que lo
hemos disfrutado increíblemente estas
experiencias realmente han marcado
nuestra vida han sido momentos que hemos
podido disfrutar
acampando en ríos en lagos jugando con
la cadena volcánica apreciando la desde
diferentes lugares de guatemala
esto nos llevó a conocer una guatemala
diferente porque podíamos recorrer y
conocer personas incluso convivir éramos
recibidos de repente en casas donde nos
permitían acampar en su patio y era como
que amables así es que empezamos a tener
estas convivencias empezaron a haber
momentos en los que ya nos disparamos a
todos los lugares que pudimos y esos
recuerdos se quedaron gratamente
grabados gracias a que mi esposo es
fotógrafo de paisaje y eso pues nos
llevaba a captar cada cosa que veíamos
el tema fue que en algún momento
decidimos regresar a algunos lugares que
habíamos disfrutado y queríamos que
poder nuevamente respirar o ver eso que
habíamos apreciado volvimos al lago más
bello del mundo después de unos años
esto fue en el 2015 y pudimos comprobar
que lamentablemente estaba cubierto de
una capa increíble pestilente
contaminada que no nos dejó acampar como
antes vaciamos
esto nosotros en su momento decidimos
denunciarlo publicarlo qué es lo que
usualmente podemos hacer verdad es
tocamos algunas puertas pero no hubo
respuesta la basura empezó a ser una
constante en esos paisajes que tanto
habíamos amado así es que decidimos
y decidimos seguir con nuestros viajes
vamos a ver y empezamos a darnos cuenta
que por ejemplo nuestros mismos desechos
la verdad porque no puedo culpar a nadie
mi página mi cepillo de dientes los
zapatos de repente de mi esposo me los
fue encontrar en las desembocaduras del
río motagua me los fui a encontrar en
las desembocaduras del pacífico' y me
empecé a dar cuenta que yo había pagado
mi servicio de extracción de basura se
había ido en un camión totalmente legal
y se había ido a un vertedero legal pero
de repente me encontré un árbol saturado
de bolsas cuando el que cuando el río
motagua sube su nivel deja así todo a su
paso
empezamos a ver los bordes del río
creyendo que eran helechos y realmente
está saturado de bolsas plásticas esto
de verdad nos llevó a
pensar que debíamos de hacer algo
tuvimos una experiencia en el río
polochic donde pudimos desayunar y le
pedimos al lanchero por favor apague la
lancha trajimos nuestro desayuno
disfrutemos en familia y los monos
saraguatos despertando y era aquella
sensación hermosa pero teníamos a la par
esta compañía que no esperábamos así fue
como fundamos water sports la primera
tour operadora con visión social y
ambiental en guatemala registrada en la
mesa de turismo de voluntariado de
inguat con la intención de poner manos a
la obra el asunto como no teníamos
conocimientos ni éramos expertos en
temas ambientales lo único que podíamos
hacer era recoger basura así es que
empezamos a poner nuestra página a las
órdenes para esto hicimos una
convocatoria e increíblemente las
personas se presentaron y esta fue
nuestra primera limpia está en san pedro
la laguna que de hecho hoy es uno de los
municipios ecológicos esto fue en junio
del 2016
decidimos elegirlo porque la primera
pregunta que recibimos siempre es para
qué lo vas a hacer y dónde vas a llevar
la basura pues nosotros investigamos un
poquito y nos enteramos que tenían una
planta de desechos en ese momento la
verdad era un poco caótica la situación
el día de hoy es un modelo y aparte de
eso porque tenía un volcán y era nuestra
extra pasión así es que decidimos ir con
un equipo
ver el volcán de hecho la siguiente vez
ya no ya no tuvimos que hacer una
limpieza porque estaba gratamente limpio
y la siguiente ocasión fue para
simplemente remozar el refugio y
nosotros pues también decidimos hacer la
actividad de limpieza luego de eso
prácticamente les puedo decir esa
historia hemos repetido la actividad en
55 lugares verdad diferentes hemos
estado desde ríos playas antigua
guatemala
municipios del interior donde hemos sido
no sólo actuando sino también educando
hemos tenido afluencia de muchas
personas nosotros somos una iniciativa
totalmente apolítica laica multicultural
inclusiva donde lo único que nos une es
el deseo de recuperar estos paisajes no
aceptamos el hecho de que guatemala vaya
a perder un tesoro tan grande como el
que tiene naturalmente y que además es
una fuente de ingresos
y sostenibilidad para las comunidades
cuando nosotros damos por perdida esa
basura no entendemos que estamos también
acabando con oportunidades de muchas
personas geniales en el interior cuando
nos hemos dado el espacio para ir a
conocer nos hemos encontrado con jóvenes
adultos personas de toda clase social en
todos los estratos interesadísimos en
levantar en recuperar esos paisajes más
de 5000 personas han participado en
nuestras actividades y el trabajo en
equipo ha sido la clave hemos ido
haciendo alianzas hemos llamado hemos
tocado puertas hemos contado con apoyo
para transporte con apoyo para postales
con apoyo para poner incluso hasta
sonido a veces y si y cuando no se ha
podido porque no hay fondos verdad no
somos ninguna ong
cada uno de los voluntarios ha pagado su
participación y así es como nos hemos
extendido a tantísimos lugares de hecho
aquí tenemos una imagen bueno de
diferentes grupos donde hemos trabajado
y uno de los casos memorables que nos
llevaremos en esta vida es el hecho de
que unimos esfuerzos con una con dos
iniciativas muy fuertes para un proyecto
de reforestación en la sierra del
lacandón
todo estaba preparado habían pasado dos
años de trámite el proyecto estaba
concluido las semillas estaban
recolectadas pero faltaba algo ellos
querían hacer una dispersión aérea y no
había un helicóptero para hacerlo
decidimos poner en la página el llamado
para poder buscar un helicóptero y de
hecho pusimos se busca helicóptero para
una misión muy especial y así fue
la semana pasada a cuatro días de que
las semillas llegaran al punto donde
ella estaban germinando y ya no iban a
ser posible tirarlas podemos ver aquí la
fuerza aérea se presentó y nos llevó el
helicóptero para que pudiéramos hacer
esta dispersión 500.000 semillas fueron
tiradas fueron sembradas fueron
dispersadas en la sierra del lacandón y
sabemos que eso es un patrimonio que va
a beneficiar a las futuras generaciones
hemos tenido también la experiencia
como san cristóbal acasaguastlán uno de
los pueblos donde hemos ido a visitar y
hemos logrado que la artesanía de pino
que descubrimos ha y la hemos logrado
enlazar con personas que tienen
comercios conscientes actualmente ellos
están generando dinero están generando
ingresos estas mujeres habilidosas que
anteriormente nadie conocía así es que
los invitamos a que puedan ver verdad lo
que están ellos trabajando también hemos
estado trabajando en el parque nacional
pacaya por tres años y hemos la primera
vez fue porque nos dijeron que no iba a
haber reforestación debido a que la
gestión se había detenido y como eso es
una cuestión que a nosotros realmente
nos preocupa decidimos lanzar en la
página el llamado para recolectar
árboles eran 8.000 árboles y el primer
año recolectamos 16.000 actualmente
llevamos alrededor de 35 mil árboles
restaurando la cuenca de la laguna
calderas y hemos hecho también llamados
para poder
ir con los grupos a plantar árboles
porque las familias no solo se quieren
quedar con que dieron el arbolito sino
que también quieren participar y aquí
uno de los ejemplos que realmente a
nosotros nos toca el corazón él es rafa
es su amiguita fuimos una vez a hacer
una limpia ton en paz un rafa ya nos
conocía y nos estuvo oa zapeando aquí
horas vienen los estoy esperando era un
domingo en la mañana y nosotros tuvimos
un atraso y le digo mira rafa ya vamos a
llegar
espérame por favor en la municipalidad
porque el alcalde va a tener la
amabilidad de recibirlos y efectivamente
rafa estaba ahí y cuando llegamos el
alcalde pues nos colocó al frente
rafa estaba en el público y cuando me
cedieron la palabra yo le dije mire
señor alcalde le quiero contar que aquí
hay alguien de patzún y rafa por favor
ponte de pie
rafa se puso de pie e increíblemente él
se dirigió al alcalde y le dijo señor
alcalde buenos días
pertenezco a una asociación juvenil
queremos recuperar la belleza de nuestro
municipio
hace unos días le vine a dejar una carta
donde le solicitaba su apoyo para que
logremos esta meta no he recibido
respuesta
yo tendí trágame tierra pero rafa hablo
con tanta cordura y gallardía y
liderazgo que de verdad se grabó en
nuestro corazón y dijimos bueno tenemos
un compromiso tenemos un compromiso muy
fuerte porque nosotros la generación que
pasó del televisor blanco y negro a de
repente a color al control remoto y
ahora el smartphone que nos mantiene
bastante distraídos tenemos un
compromiso para dejarles a ellos un
mejor país para restaurar y recuperar
los recursos naturales de guatemala
el la verdad nos hace a nosotros
reflexionar y pensar que debemos
trabajar y debemos crear espacios para
ellos no sólo verlos y creer que no
tienen algo importante que decirnos
realmente los jóvenes están muy
comprometidos y eso nos lleva a una
reflexión una de nuestras frases
favoritas cuando un hombre planta un
árbol bajo cuya sombra sabe que no habrá
de sentarse ha entendido el sentido de
la vida gracias
[Música]